[موسيقى]
احييكم مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه الانتخابات
النصفيه في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ما
زالت مستمره على شاشه العربيه اذا قد يخرج
الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن من هذه
الانتخابات خاسرا كل شيء اذا ما قرر
الامريكيون منحه مجلس الشيوخ والنواب الى
الجمهوريين وبالتالي سيحولون الباقي من
رئاسته الى جموده زميلنا صائب الشعير
سيصحابنا في تفاصيل هذه الانتخابات
نتابعها سويا
[موسيقى]
ما يجب ان نعرفه عن الانتخابات النصفيه في
امريكا كما تعلمون انتخابات الرئاسه
الامريكيه تجرى كل اربع سنوات وهذا
الاختيار رئيسا للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الانتخابات النصفيه هي تجرى كل
سنتين وسميت نصفيه لانها تاتي في منتصف
ولايه الرئيس
لماذا هي مهمه الانتخابات النصفيه ولانها
في منتصف ولايه الرئيس فهي بمثابه استفتاء
حقيقي على مدى رضا الامريكيين عن اداء
رئيسهم واذا كانوا يرغبون في تعطيل
قراراته بانتخاب اغلبيه في الكونجرس من
الحزب الاخر
يتعلق الامر كله بمن يسيطر على هذا المبنى
الكونجرس يعود الامر الى عام
1787 عندما قرر واضع الدستور الامريكي ان
البرلمان سيتكون من غرفتين وهذا ما حصلوا
عليه
الكونجرس يتكون من غرفتين مجلس النواب ب
435 مقعدا وتبقا للماده الاولى من الدستور
الامريكي ينتخب اعضاء مجلس النواب كل
سنتين اما مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
ينتخب الشيوخ فيها كل ست سنوات
[موسيقى]
السباق في الانتخابات النصفيه بين الحزبين
الديمقراطي والجمهوري يكون على
435 مقعدا في مجلس النواب اي كامل المجلس
وخمسه وثلاثين مقعدا من مجلس الشيوخ اي
ثلث اعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذي يضم 100 مقعد
كذلك ينتخب الامريكيون في هذا الثامن من
نوفمبر اعضاء المجالس المحليه وحكام 36
ولايه من اصل 50 ولايه امريكيه
الوضع الحالي الديمقراطيون لديهم اغلبيه
ضئيله في مجلس النواب منذ عام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس باغلبيه مجلس النواب
في الانتخابات النصفيه ثلاث مرات فقط اما
مجلس الشيوخ فهو منقسم بخمسين مقعدا لكل
الحزبين وسيجري التنافس على 34 مقعدا منها
في هذه الانتخابات النصفيه
منذ العام
1934 فاز حزب الرئيس 6 مرات باغلبيه مجلس
الشيوخ وفي مره واحده فقط لم يحصل تغير
للاغلبيه في المسجد
ساتوقف الان مشاهدينا مع جورجيا
الانتخابات في جورجيا هذا العام لها
خصوصيه شديده فكما نرى قد تحسم الولايه
الاغلبيه لاحد الحزبين في مجلس الشيوخ بين
المرشحين الجمهوري هيرشي الوكر وديمقراطيه
رافاييلر ايضا لنفس الولايه تاثير كبير
على نتائج الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
فالفائز بها يحصل على 16 صوتا في المجمع
الانتخابي وهذا مهم جدا هذه مشاهدين ايضا
خريطه نتائج انتخابات في ولايات الجنوب
الشرقيه عام 2016 كانت بين هلالكلنتر
ودونالد ترامب ايضا كما نرى ذهبت جميعها
الى المرشح الجمهوري انا ذات الرئيس
السابق ترامب هذه الخريطه ايضا ت الان
نتائج الولايات في انتخابات عام 2020 كانت
طبعا بين الجوبايدن وترامب كل هذه
الولايات ذهبت لترامب لذلك نراها حمراء ما
عدا جورجيا هو الامر الذي لم يصدقه ترامب
واكد وجود تزوير في نتائج هذه الولايه
بالتحديد من ابرز العوامل التي تسببت بهذه
النتيجه ما هي اولا جهود الديمقراطيه
السيسي ابرامز المرشحه الديمقراطيه لمنصب
حاكم جورجيا في سباق الانتخابات الحاليه
السيسي ابرامز من هي خاضت السباق على منصب
حاكم جورج امام برايم كامل في عام 2018
لكنها في وقتها خسرت نفس السباق يتكر بين
الاثنين هذه الانتخابات ايضا حينما خسرت
التي انشئت مركزا لتشجير الناخبين من ذوي
الاصول الافريقيه في كسوف انتخابات ليكون
قوه الدفع لديمقراطيين وبالفعل مشاهدينا
نجحت في تسجيل 800000 ناخذ جديد يعتقد ان
هذه الاصوات التي سجلتها ابرامز هي التي
تسببت بفوز جو بايدن بولايه جورجيا في
الانتخابات عام 2020
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا في هذه الانتخابات كما
اسلفنا منذ قليل تتنافس مجددا استيس
ابرامز على منصب الحاكم مع الجمهوريه
ابراهيم كامل سباق لا يهتم به ترامب كثيرا
لماذا لانه يريد ان يخسر الاثنان لو كان
ذلك ممكنا
الحاكم الجمهوريه الحالي رفض الاسراء
لترامب خلال الانتخابات 2020 حينما طلب
منه وقفه اعتماد تصفيه
وتظهر استطلاعات الراي ان كان سيحصل على
ولايه جديده في جورجيا رغم كل جهود سيسي
ابرا برنس
ايضا يوجد سباق على منصب سكريتير الولايه
وهو المنصب المسؤول مباشره على الاشراف
على الانتخابات الرئاسيه بعد سنتين يسال
جمهوريه
الى ولايه جديده هذا الرجل ايضا يكرهه
ترامب كثيرا رغم انه كان من داعمي ترامب
الاقوياء الا ان كل شيء تغير ما انتخابات
عام 2020 حينما طلب منه ترامب ان يفتش على
اكثر من 11 احد 10 الفساوت لصالحه لقلب
نتيجه امام بيضاء عندها رفض رافلز برجر
طلب ترامب والشهيد ضده ايضا في تحقيقات
الكونغرس بشان اقتحام الكابيتال في السادس
من يناير وتم نشره تسريب للمحادثه
الهاتفيه بينه وبين ترامب
سياده فيفا
[موسيقى]
والله بنت يا اوشن
ساحه انتخابيه حاسمه في انتخابات التجديد
النصفي زميلنا حسين الطارود عدلنا هذا
التقرير من هناك
نتحدث مع زملائنا المنتشرين في الولايات
الامريكيه
الانتخابات النصفيه حتى هذا العام في
الولايات المتحده يحدث هنا في ولايه
جورجيا في المنافسه على اشدها بين
الجمهوريين والديمقراطيين على منصب حاكم
الولايه ومقعدي مجلس الشيوخ الذي قد تتحدث
السيطره عليه في السباق بين عضو المجلس
الحالي الديمقراطي رافاييل وراك ومنافسه
الجمهوري
لهذا يرى محللون ان جورجيا اصبحت ساحه
انتخابيه حاسمه
انتخابيه حاسمه لثلاثه اسباب اولا
الجمهوريون بحاجه ماسه للحصول عليها ليكون
اغلبيه في مجلس الشيوخ ثانيا تتجه جورجيا
نحو الديمقراطيه مثل ولايات اخرى في
الجنوب مع كل الجمهوريين واخيرا تبدو
جورجيا مثل بقيه الامه وما يحدث فيها قد
يظهر لنا ما سيحدث على الصعيد الوطني
في انتخابات عام 2020 تحولت الولايه
الجمهوريه الى اللون الازرق رمز
الديمقراطيين بعدما فاز جو بيدن باصوات
مجمعه الانتخابيه وخسر الجمهوريون مقعديها
في مجلس الشيوخ ما اعطى الديمقراطيين فرصه
في احدى معاقل الجمهوريين يريدون الحفاظ
عليها
خلال اربع سنين
جورج
جمهوري لحاكم جمهوري ولكن لمجلس الشيوخ
ديمقراطي لذلك ممكن انه جورجيا تروح يا
ديمقراطيين يجمهوريين
لكن المهمه امام الديمقراطيين ستكون صعبه
بعد تعديل الولايه لقانونها الانتخابي
الذي يفرض قيودا جديده على التصويت قالت
وزاره العدل انها تهدف الى حرمان او تقليص
حق التصويت للامريكيين من اصول الافريقيه
الذين دعموا انتخاب بيضا وفوز
الديمقراطيين في مقعدي مجلس
الشيوخذه
احد مشكلات القانون الجديد انه يقيد عدد
الاماكن التي يمكنك فيها التصويت ببطاقات
الاختراع الغيابيه ويقيد مقدار الوقت ذلك
وكانت بطاقات الاقتراع الغيابيه هذه اكثر
الديمقراطيه في العامين الماضيين لذلك
بشكل اساسي سيؤدي هذا الى القضاء على بعض
المكاسب التي حققها الديمقراطيون في
جورجيا في الانتخابات القليله الماضيه حيث
تحقق اداء جيدا في انتخابات الاعاده
التي ينسب اليها الفضل بفوز الديمقراطيين
في الولايه الحاكمه الجمهوريه الحاليه
كامبا وهما يتنافسان على المنصب للمره
الثانيه بعد انتخابات عام 2018 بعد خسارته
مقعدائه الولايه في مجلس الشيوخ في
الانتخابات السابقه
يسعى لاستعاده احد المقعدين من
الديمقراطيين فيما تشتد المنافسه على منصب
حاكم الولايه الذي يعمل الديمقراطيون
للفوز به ما يزيد من احتدام المعركه
الانتخابيه ويجعل جورجيا الساحه
الانتخابيه الحاسمه حسين الطاوض العربيه
من مدينه اطلنطا في ولايه جورجيا
حسين زميلنا يبقى معنا من جوجل ينضم الينا
من بنسلفانيا ايضا بير غانم و منيورك طلال
الحاج طبعا زملائنا
المنتشرون في مختلف الولايات اهلا بكم
سابدا معك حسين همم ماذا كيف هو يبدو
المشهد الان في الساعات الاولى لبدا هذا
الاقتراع
صباح الخير ميسون تحيه لك طبعا نتوقع
اليوم اقبالنا كبيرا من الناخبين لاسيما
في ظل الاقبال الذي شهدناه في التصويت
المبكر والذي بلغ من يونان ونصف
محمد اوز الجمهوري همم الذي طبعا الذي هو
يترشح على مقعد سنه
الان يبدو يتوجه الى مركز الاقتراع يبدو
انه اقترع وخرج الان طبعا همم نتابع ايضا
ال- وسائل الاعلاميه كلها متواجده امام
مركز الاقتراع
ويتابعون لحظه اقتراع الذي خرج الان طبعا
المعروف بان الرئيس ترامب يؤيده همم كثيرا
ولكن طبعا نتائج سنكون بانتظارها في
الايام لاحقا لمعرفه كيف اختار الامريكيون
وخاصه في بنسلفانيا ساعود اليك حسين تفضل
نعم كنا نتحدث عن الاقبال اليوم واننا قد
نشاهد اقبالا كبيرا نظرا ارقام التي سجلت
في التصويت المبكر والتي بلغت نحو اكثر من
مليونين و500,000 ناخذوا باصواتهم في
التصويت المبكر في زياده 18% مقارنه بعام
2020 عندما همم صوت عفن عام 2018 عندما
صوت 1,800,000 ناخذ في التصويت المبكر
المنافسه ميسون هنا بين هيرشل ووكر عن
الحزب الجمهوري من ترامب ومن ايضا زعيم
الجمهوريين في مجلس الشيوخ وهذه همم نادره
تقريبا في هذه الانتخابات مع همم رفاييل
السينما تقديمقراطي الحالي الذي يدعمه
بطبيعه الحال همم الحزب الديمقراطي والجل-
ال- ال- الوجوه البارزه من الحزب
الديمقراطي همم على مستوى منصب الحاكم كما
ذكرنا في التقرير المنافسه تحتدم بين
السيسي ابرامز التي ينسب لها الف بيفوز
الديمقراطيين بمقعدي مجلس الشيوخ خلال
الانتخابات 2020 وايضا بفوز بايدن مع
الحاكم الجمهوري الحالي براين كامب الذي
يحظى بتاييد كما يقال هنا من الناخبين
المستقلين بسبب السياسات التي اتبعها على
المستوى المحلي نحن نعلم ان الانتخابات
المتعلقه بمنصب الحاكم الاهتمام يكون على
قوانين المحليه
لكم همم كم له بفضل في الكثير بالنسبه
لقانون اصلاح الضرائب وايضا بالنسبه
لزياده الاجور لموظفي الولايه
الى زميلنا كان
غانمتك اولا ولكن نريد ايضا ان تطلعنا على
اجواء هذا اليوم الانتخابيه لديك وهل نحن
امام انتخابات حسب شخصيه المرشح ام حقيقه
انتخابات بين الجمهوريين وادي
انا امام مركز اقتراع في وسط حارس بيرجع
عاصمه الولايه هناك شيء غريب انه منذ
الصباح منذ ساعه حتى الان لم نرى اكثر من
10 او 15 شخصا جاؤوا الى هذا المكان
باصواتهم هذا امر يجب ان يشغل البال
الطرفين خصوصا الديمقراطيين لانها هذه
مخرطيين يريدون من ناخذهم ان يتوجهوا الى
صناديق الاقتراع وان يزيدوا من حماسهم همم
بهذه الاصوات وعدم الادلاء بالاصوات هو
مؤشر سيء جدا بالنسبه للديمقراطيين ولكنه
ليس اخر العالم هذه المعركه همم اشردي قبل
قليل الى ان امامه اوز محمد اوز ادلى همم
بصوته همم في هذه الانتخابات طبعا هو
شخصيه همم تليفزيونيه معروفه جدا لدى
الامريكيين معروف ايضا لدى اهل
البنسلفانيا همم المقابل هناك جون سترمن
وهو نائب الحاكم وهو مرشح ضد محمد اوزلي
يشغل منصب في مجلس الشيوخ الامريكي اين هي
المشكله المشكله ان فترمن اصيب بجلطه
دماغيه كانت كان يتقدم على محمد اوز بعشر
دقائق وتضاء على هذا التقدم الى السفر
واصبحوا الان في معركه متقاربه جدا من
يفوز في هذه الانتخابات من الصعب جدا ان
نقول من سوف يفوز في هذه الانتخابات هناك
مشكله شخصيه اكثر من ما هي مشكله حزبيه
فالناس هنا لا يصوطون للحزب الجمهوري فقط
او الحزب الديمقراطيه فقط انما يصوتنا
لفتره
طلال الحاج طلال نيويورك
ديمقراطيه بقوه ولكن همم الان كيف تبدو
الاجواء هل هناك تخوف من قبل الحزب
الديمقراطي ان يخسر منصب الحاكم مثلا
نعم انا اقف هنا ميسون امام احدى همم
مراكز الاقتراع وترونه همم وراء الناس وهم
يدنون باصواتهم هذا الصباح الباكر بدات من
الساعه السادسه صباحا عمليه الاقتراع فعلا
منصب الحاكم الولايه ومنصب ممثل ولايه في
مجلس الشيوخ وهو شك شومر زعيم
الديمقراطيين في داخل مجلس الشيوخ
مراكز مهمه وحيويه في هذه همم الولايه
الديمقراطيه بامتياز همم منصب الحاكم مهم
اربعه من حكام هذه الولايه اصبحوا فيما
بعد رؤساء الولايات المتحده مارتن بانبو
روفر
سته منهم من حكام اصبح انه نواب رئيس
الجمهوريه رئيس الولايات المتحده واثنان
منهم شغله منصب كبير القضاه في المحكمه
الامريكيه العليا مناصب مهمه هؤلاء الحكام
الولايه لها تاريخ عريق في هذه ولكن كما
تفضلت قلعه من قلاع الولايات الولايات
الديمقراطيه ولا تضاهيها في ذلك سوى
كاليفورنيا ويكتسب السباق على منصب حاكم
الولايه اهميه كبيره جدا وخاصه همم ان
كثرين هوجل ستكون اذا نجحت في هذه
الانتخابات
والفوز بمنصب حاكم الولايه ستكون اول
امراه في تاريخ نيويورك تصل الى هذا
المنصب بالانتخاب حصلت على هذا المنصب قبل
شهر بضعه شهور فيها اغسط الماضي بسبب
فضيحه والان هناك طبعا همم السيناتور همم
وهو يواجه منافسه قويه من جوه بنيان وهو
الجمهوري المرشح لهذا المنصب
ويبدو انه شك شوبر ربما يفوز ولكن بفارق
بسيط وهذا انحدث سيخرع سيق نواقيس الخطر
بالنسبه للحزب الديمقراطيه في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده اما اذا خسر زعيم الحزب
في شك شومر في مجلس الشيوخ هذه كارثه
للحزب ولن تبشر بخير بقيه الاعضاء في مجلس
الشيوخ اذا خسر الزعيمهم في ولايه نيويورك
سيكون اسبوعا طويلا وصعبا خاصه ان عدد من
المراقبين يتوقعون وخساره الديمقراطيين
لسيطرهم على مجلس النواب
وتظل العيون مصاب على ولايات واسكان
جورج
للحصول على النتائج باقرب وقت ممكن
على كل حال الان ايضا انه نتابع سويا
مشاهدينا تمرين المرشح الديمقراطي لمنصب
السيناتور ايضا همم يبدو بانه بصوته وهناك
ايضا
سباق محتدم جدا همم بينه هو بين ال جمهوري
جايبيفانس همم ايضا حسب استطلاعات الراي
مشاهدينا كنا لاحظنا بانه تقدم على تمرين
في هذه الولايات همم
الان يبدو بان هذا
المنصب عليه تنافس كبير وديمقراطيون
يريدون الحفاظ على هذا المقعد باي شكل من
الاشكال اذا تمرين همم ادلى بصوته والان
يعطي كلمه همم الى وسائل الاعلام
المتواجده خارج مركز الاقتراب قبل ان ننهي
معكم زملائنا ساتوقف مره جديده مع حسين
لدي اظن همم دقيقه من الوقت يعتبر حسين
بانه بسبب النتائج المتقاربه حسب
استطلاعات الراي من الممكن ان تكون جورجيا
لديها جوله ثالثه وخاصه بانه يبدو بانه هي
التي ستكون الحكم
سيكون مجلس الشيوخ ومن سيكون الرابح في
هذه الانتخابات لماذا هذا التوقع
ميسون لان نتائج استطاعات الراي متقاربه
بينورناك وكر
والقانون في جورجيا ينص على انه اذا لم
يحصل الفائز على 50% من الاصوات فسيذهب
الى جوله اعاده تجد الاشاره هنا والتذكير
بان والرناك اصلا كنفذ في جوله الاعاده
عام 2021 همم هذا هو القانون في جورجيا
النتائج متقاربه التنافس شديد بين الرجل
همم كان حتى البدايه شهر نوفمبر استطلاعات
الراي تشير الى تفوق ولكن منذ بدايه
نوفمبر بدانا نرى ان استطلاعات الراي تشير
الى تقدم الان هيرشي ووكر على وورد لهذا
السبب نحن نتوقع ان لا تحسم النتائج لا
اليوم ولا غدا وان يكون هناك جوله اعاده
طبعا ال- ال- المرشحات في الحقيقه يدفعان
همم الى عدم الذهاب الى هذه الجوله يا
حسان الناخبين على التصويت بكثافه من اجل
حسب ال- ال- النتيجه اليوم كما قال
البارحه هرش الوكر قال لنا اليوم ستكون
تحسب النتيجه سينتصر الجمهوريون ولكن
استطلاعات الراي لها راي اخر تقول بان
الموضوع قد نذهب هناك احتمال قوي لان نذهب
الى جوله اعاده في السادس منذ السمبر
المقبل اشكركم زملائنا دائما سنكون معكم
في هذه التغطيه المستمره على شاشه العربيه
من جورجيا حسين الطارود من بانسلفانيا بير
غانم منيو طلال الحاج اشكركم زملائنا
سنتوقف الان مع هذه الكلمه التي كنا
نتبعناها منذ قليل عبر الصوره لتمرين همم
الديمقراطي لمنصب السنتر
استمتعنا كثير انا اخرجنا من المدرسه
الاسبوع العشره ايام ماضيه وكانت تجربه
جيده يعملن على مهارات التحدث امام العامه
وكان
رائعا جدا حتى اعددنا اللعبات واستمتع
بوقته ايضا
حتى دي واجباته المنزليه والمعلمه كانت
لطيفه جدا
وساعدتك كثيرا
وقام بكل اعماله هي على الحافله حتى بين
الكلمات كانت ممتعه
عندما يكبر الشخص في هذه المنطقه
هذه بلادي
افضل شيء في الحمله كانت اللقاء الاشخاص
من امثالنا من بلدات مختلفه واسماء مختلفه
ومدن مختلفه وظائف مختلفه ايضا ولكن
الحمد لله
ونعود لهذه التغطيه المستمره عبر شاشه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
دع الرئيس
الامريكيين الى التصويت في هذه الانتخابات
النصفيه وغردقه
انه يوم الانتخابات اجعلوا اصواتكم مسموعه
فيسبوك
منور يا عصام منور
لتقترب من ادنى مستوياتها خلال فتره
رئاستهم
الذي اجري على مدار يومين تراجع شعبيه
الرئيس الامريكي الى 39%
ويعزز تراجع شعبيه بايضا التوقعات بان
يفوز الجمهوريون بمجلس النواب ومن المحتمل
ايضا مجلس الشيوخ
اذن مشاهدينا نتوقف الان مع هذه الصور
للمرشح حج جون فترمان المرشح طبعا في
بنسلفانيا ومن المعروف بانه جانفيط من
اصيب بجلطه دماغيه منذ خمسه اشهر حسب
الاقبال على تصويت اليوم في بنسلفانيا جدا
يعني هو يقف كان امام مركز
10 اشخاص ذهبوا لهذا الاقتراع وحسب ايضا
زميلنا بانه تدني الاقتراع ايضا ليس جيدا
بالنسبه للحزبين ان كانت ديمقراطيه او
الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا العربيه تنقل لكم كل
التفاصيل من الاستديوهاتنا في دبي ولكن
الان ايضا سننتقل الى استديو واشنطن مع
ناديه بلبيسي لتحاور امال مدلله السفير
السابقه في الامم المتحده وايضا الباحث في
الشعر الامريكي احمد الحنطي سيكون ضيوف
زميلتنا ناديه بلبيسي ناديه اليك الهواء
لكم الان ونحن ونستمع الى هذه التحليلات
من مكتب واشنطن في العرب
شكرا لك ميسون واهلا بكم اعزائي المشاهدين
في هذه التغطيه المفتوحه من السيديهاتنا
في العاصمه الامريكيه واشنطن طبعا الكثير
من القضايا التي اثيرت في هذه الانتخابات
الاقتصاد التضخم حمل السلاح الاجهاض ومصير
الديمقراطيه واستفتاء على اداء الرئيس
ومستقبل الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
الكثير من القضايا الكثير من الاموال التي
انفقت
17.16.7 مليار دولار وهناك حماس شديد 70%
من الامريكيين قالوا بانهم سيصوطون في هذه
الانتخابات طبعا سنبحث كل هذه التفاصيل
كما ذكرت معه امل مدلل السفير السابقه في
الامم المتحده للبنان اهلا بك امانه همم
والاستاذ احمد الحنطي الباحث في شؤون
الامريكيه اهلا بك يا استاذ احمد
الرئيسيه
الجمهوريين يقولون الاقتصاد
وديمقراطيون يقولون بان الديمقراطيه في
خطر هل هذان العنوان ابدا معك امل اييه هم
الذين يشكلون الاطار العريض لهذه
الانتخابات
هامه جدا انتخابات مفصليه ليس فقط لانها
ستاتي باكثر من نصف
الكونغرس او الكونغرس كامله
ومجلس الشيوخ 35 سنه الجديد وانما لانها
ستحدد مستقبل من يدخل البيت الابيض في
2024 سنه
انها تاتي بعد ما حدث اقتحام الكونجرس
وبعد ان قدم الرئيس السابق ترامب حوالي
مرشح
ينكرون الانتخابات نتائج الانتخابات
ويقولون ان هذه النتائج اذا لم يرجعوا في
شرعيه
اذا لم ننجح هذا يعني ان الانتخابات همم
هذه الانتخابات هامه لان هذا ستحدد مستقبل
واتجاه الولايات المتحده واتجاه ال وهي
ايضا كمان قصه ذاكرتي استفتاء على سياسه
الرئيس
القادمتين ستكون صعبه جدا اذا خسر الرئيس
مثل ما كتبت امل لكن هو صعب لانه اذا سيطر
الجمهوريه كما هو متوقع على مجلس النواب
لن يستطيع الرئيس تمرير اي من القرارات
وبالتالي يصبح ولكنه رئيس تصريف اعمال
لمده عامين
في اخر سنتين ومع اوباما في اخر ست سنوات
هذا وضع طبيعي ليست هذه المشكله المشكله
المجلس الشيوخ انه اذا اخذ الجمهوريين
اغلبيه مجلس الشيوخ تتوقف التعيينات
الحكوميه والقضائيه لسنتين القادمه هذا ما
يعني قد ما ترجع الديمقراطيين في هذا
الانتخابات
هو ليس تركيبه مجلس النواب وهو مرتبط كما
هو متوقع طبعا ان يسيطر الجمهوريين لماذا
سيسيطر الجمهوريين لانه هي عمليه حسابيه
ليس كذلك خمس مقاعد فقط بحاجه الى خمس
مقاعد فقط من المتوقع انه يعني اذا كانت
ليله جيده للديمقراطيين سيحصل جمهوريها
على عشره على عشره مقاعد هذا اذا كانت
جيده اذا كانت سيئه قد يحصلون على 30 35
مقاعد نعم فبالتالي يعني حسابيا الامر شبه
محسوب لصالح الجمهوريه طبعا دائما هناك
مفاجات واستطاعات الري السنه هذه في يعني
اضعف درجات الثقه يعني الثقه فيها ضعيفه
جدا مقارنه بالدورات السابقه لاسباب عديده
ولكن هذا يعني انه همم
الديمقراطيين لا ينظرون الى اغلبيه مجلس
النواب ينظرون الى كم هذه الاغلبيه لانه
اذا كانت الاغلبيه يعني ب 20 30 هذا يعني
ان المتطرفين في ال- في ال- في الحزب
الجمهوري سيكون لهم صوت اعلى وسيتمكنون من
يعني التحكم بقياده ال- همم الجمهوريين
داخل مجلس النواب بينما اذا كانت الاقليه
ضئيله لانه يعني اخذوا 10 مقاعد كنا
اغلبيتهم بخمسه فقط يمكن ان تصبح سياسات
المتشددين الجمهوريين اقل عده اقل السيطره
على توجه الحزب يعني مثلا قد يحاولون عز
البيض مره واحده بدل عشر مرات صح
وكانت مسرحيه يعني بالنهايه
بانهما بموضوع حزبي بامتياز اي واحد من
الاطراف وكان الديمقراطوريه يحاول ان يعزل
الرئيس لكن نقطه مهمه اثرتها امل بالنسبه
لم يسمى بالموجه الحمراء التوقعات بانه
كما ذكرنا بانه الجمهوريه سيطرون لانه فقط
بحاجه الى خمس مقاعد في مجلس النواب لكن
اذا كان هناك موجه حمراء بمعنى لديهم
اريحيه بالحكم ما ذكر الاستاذ احمد على
المتطرفين هم يصفهم الرئيس باكثر من
متطرفين بانهم ننزيون جدد يصفهم بالفاشيين
وهم مؤيدين الرئيس ترامب هل نتحدث عن حاله
انقسام استقطاب غير مسبوقه في الولايات
المتحده بالطبع البنات المتحده الان اكثر
من اي مره في تاريخها في عوده الى سؤالك
الاول همم
في خطر وهو ليس الوحيد الذي يقول ذلك كل
الخبراء يقولون البعض يقول ان هذه
الانتخابات ربما تكون اخر انتخابات وقتها
في الولايات المتحده اذا نجحترام واذا نجح
الذين
مرشحون الان ويؤدن ويؤيدون ترامب نجحوا في
الوصول الحكم ربما لن يقوموا بقبول انت اي
انتخابات انتخابات امريكيه في المستقبل
فاذا الديمقراطيه الامريكيه هي في خطر
ويمكن ان اا نرى انقسام اكبر بعد
الانتخابات همم من الان وممكن عنف البعض
مال العنف ولكن
هي انهم يركزون على هذا الموضوع وهذا
الموضوع
يهتم به النخبه
الامريكي الذي يرى ان الاسعار ارتفعات وان
التضخم همم اكل همم معيشتهم
وكل همم
اكثر من 77% في لكن يكون انه الاتصال
فهذاكرنا بلينتن والشعار الذي رفع يومها
لديهم مشكله في هذا المجال ولكن الخطر
حقيقي
اذا فاشله همم الامريكيون في انتخاب
مرشحين او انتخاب مسؤولين يؤمنون
بديمقراطيه وبتبادل السلطه
وهذا هو الخطر اليوم طيب استاذ احمد ماذا
حدث في الولايات المتحده هل هي ظاهره
الرئيس ترامب مع اني كنت باجله همم ربما
ساعات قادمه نبحث في موضوع
التاثير الرئيس ترامب الذي اصبح فعليا هو
عراب الحزب الجمهوري يعني هو الذي يقرر من
سيذهب الى انتخابات مجلس النواب ومجلس شو-
والحكام اذا لم يدعمه مترام او اذا ادعمهم
وهو استفتاء على اداء الرئيس
ترامب ايضا هل ظاهره ترامب اثرت على
المبادئ التي اسست عليها الولايات المتحده
بمعنى حركه شعبو يا نظريات مؤامره تغيير
بنظام الحكم في الولايات المتحده بمعنى
بانه الان بده يشككون قبل حتى ان يصوتون
يعني قبل ما تفتح صناديق الاقتراع يقولون
بان هذه الانتخابات غير نزيه فقط اذا خسر
المرشحين المدعوين بالنسبه لترامب اين هو
الحزب الجمهوري التقليدي الذي عرفناه قبل
دخول ترامب الى معترك السياسه
لم يعد الحزب الجمهوريه الموجوده اليوم
ليس الحزب الجمهوري قبل يعني 10 سنوات
من خلال هذه الفتره القصيره بشكل كبير
ولكن التغيير يعني ترامب نتيجه وليس سبب
ترامب يعني ركب الموجه اللي بدات في منتصف
في التسعينات وتمكن يعني من قيادتها
باحترافيه
واحكام السيطره همم لكن هي بدايه
الاستقطاع بالحادث بدات يعني تظهر لنا
التسعينات بدا الجمهوريون يحولون
الانتخابات مجلس النواب تحديدا
الى انتخابات وطنيه انت تصوت لصالح عضو
كونجرس عن مقاطعتك ولكن نظرتك على مستوى
الوطن وليس على مستوى مصالحك الخاصه او
المصالح مقاطعتك هذه بدات معنود كينج في
التسعينات واستمرت في التفاعل
رئيس مجلس النواب في عهد كلاينتر وزادت مع
سنوات حتى يعني حتى ترامب استطاع اختطاف
الحزب ايضا الحزب الجمهوري قاعده كانت
تاكل قبل ترامب ولكن ترامب تمكن من ادخال
في فئه جديده لم تكن تشارك بالانتخابات
سابقا دخلت خصيصا من اجل ترامب ودخلوا مع
الحزب الجمهوري اصبحوا ناشطين يعني يصوتن
حتى في الانتخابات الاوليه بكثافه وهذا
غير معتاد على الناقد الذي يدخل جديده هذا
جعل القيادات التقليديه في الحزب
الجمهوريه امام واحد من خيارين اما يعني
احنا اللي موجود او الخروج من الحزبه
انك كثيرون خرجوا من الحجم اعضاء
تقاعده او خسروا او كانوا يعني ناشطين
واستراتيجيين يعملون مع الحزب من قبل ابو
علي صبحي يعملون ضده لانهم معرضين لهذه
الموجه هناك
الولايات المتحده محكومه من قبل حزبان
كمال عفوا الديمقراطي والجمهوري هل هناك
همم امكانيه لان يكون هناك حزب اخر يعني
نحن نتحدث عن اصوات المستقلين سواء
الانتخابات الرئاسيه او الانتخابات
المحليه يعني بمعنى بانه هذول الناس لا
يرون لا يرون انفسهم في اي من الحسبين
يريدون تغيير لكن هل النظام السياسي
الامريكي بكل الاموال تتحدث عن 16 مليار
دولار اللي تصور اكم دوله من الدول
الناميه يمكن ان تكون هذه الميزانيه
الميزانيه دوله يعني تصرف على هذه
الانتخابات وبالنهايه نحصل على حاله
الاستقطاب على يمكن ان يكون هناك ترجمه
لعنف سياسي يرافقه للانتخابات وعدم رضا
بالنهايه لماذا الولايات المتحده فشلت حتى
الان في ان همم يكون هناك حزب ثالث يمثل
المستقلين الذين لا يريدون ان يكونوا في
هذا الحزب اولاد الواقع
ان هناك ازمه الاحزاب في امريكا اجمل ان
الحزبين الجمهوري يؤدي نقاطي بعنان يعاني
من ازمه طبعا الازمه
الحزب الجمهوري اكبر
ونراها همم على السطح ولكن هناك ايضا داخل
الحزب الديمقراطي حيث ان البرجسف
لا لا لا
يلتزمون بكل سياسات الرئيس
الامريكي
هذا الواقع السياسي نراه الان لم يكن هكذا
ابدا في تاريخ امريكا استقطاب همم كبير
وهذا الاستقطاب ادى الى غالبيه صامته لا
توافق لا تتفق مع
رافعين ونرى هذا في نتيجه في الاقبال على
الانتخابات
النتيجه عاده بلبايات المتحده غير مرتفعه
جدا ولكنها الان هناك الكثير من الناس
لينتخبون انهم يرون ان هذا النزاع وهذا
التوتر الموجود لا يمثلهم كان هناك محاوله
قبل عده شهور في بعض الاشخاص تكلموا عن عن
الحزب جديد ولكن لم نرى اي شيء حتى الان
لم نرى اي بذوغ لاي حزب جديد ولكن اعتقد
اذا استمر همم الحزب الجمهوري في الاكل
نفسه تاكل والانتهاء سنرى همم شيء مختلف
في المحافظين بين المحافظين لان هناك حاجه
لان يكون هناك همم حزب معتدل همم يواجه او
اعترف معتدل يواجه هذا التطرف في الحزب
الجمهوري الكثير من القضايا التي طرحنا في
هذه الساعه سنتابعها في الساعه القادمه
ومنها توسيع القاعده للحزب الجمهوري انت
ضم اقليات لم تكن في السابق مثل
الامريكيين الوصول الافريقيه واللاتينيين
وطبعا تاثير الرئيس الترام السابق على
الحزب همم شكرا لكم حتى هذه اللحظه سنعود
لمناقشه كل هذه القضايا على مدى اليوم
نعود اليك ميسون ونتابع معا التغطيه من
ستدياتنا في دبي شكرا لك وايضا لضيفي
دائما سنكون معكي ومع باقي الزملاء في
كافه الولايات الامريكيه ونحن الان ايضا
نتابع هذه التغطيه من استديوهاتنا في دبي
اذا امكانيه ظهور دونالد ترامب اخر ضئيله
لكنها صحفا امريكيه اكدت ان الرئيس السابق
قد يواجه منافسه شديده من اكثر ورثته
اخلاصا في الانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله
والمتمثله بحاكم فلوريدا راندس فالاخير
نسخه محدثه ولكنها اكثر انضباطا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الوحش الذي صنعه الرئيس السابق دونالد
ترامب وفق وصف الاعلام الامريكي قد يصارعه
على عريينه لامتلاكه الصفات نفسها ممزوجه
بالانضباط والابتعاد عن الفضائح
الترامبيه اخلاصا وهو حاكم فلوريدا منذ
عام 2019 ومرشح للمنصب نفسه مجددا بيكا
السياسيه المستقبليه اي انه لم يؤكد او
ينفي نيه الترشح للرئاسه لكن نسمه اوقحيما
في دائره المنافسين المحتملين للترامب اذا
قرر الاخيره حوض سباق الرئاسه بعد عامين
على اعتبار انه يعمل في ازقه السلطه
الخلفيه التي كانت من اختصاص ترامب ويضع
في جعبته نقاطه تفوق تتمثل بتكتكه الاكثر
دقه فهو لا يضرب خصومه بمراكز ضعفهم او
يستخدم صفاتهميه ووفق الاستطلاعاته تهديدا
كبيرا للرئيس السابق ويمتلك فرصه متعدده
للوصول للبيت الابيض تتمثل اولا بصغر سنه
وقد سجل تق بنسب ضئيله على ترامب في
ولايات مثل نيو هامشر في ترشيح الحزب
الجمهوري للرئاسه عام 2024
الحاكم الجمهوري الذي بدا مسيرته السياسيه
قبل عشر سنوات بنيله مقعدا بمجلس النواب
عرف بسياساته المناهضه للقيود المشدده
التي فرضتها رائحه كورونا وكان الاسرع
بتنفيذ رغبه ترامب باعاده فتح الاقتصاد
مواقفه مشابهه في الدعم غير المحدود
لاسرائيل ورفض الاتفاق مع ايران والتشدد
مع الصين دي سانتوس قد يكون نسخه محدثه
واقل حده من الرئيس السابق لكن وفق صحف
امريكيه فامتعه ترامب وما تشمله من طريقه
اثاره انصاره الى لا مبالاته تجاه خصومه
السياسيين ووسائل الاعلام والارتجال
والنرجسيه عده ليس هناك ترامب من دونها
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الى هنا ينتقم ينتهي لقاء بكم
ولكن التغطيه على العربيه مستمره ابقى
معنا
[موسيقى]